et d'ailleurs on va en parler avec
florian mais les risques et professeur
au département des sciences économiques
de l'uqam
bonjour monsieur minery au jour
j'aimerais d'ailleurs qu'on aborde la
discussion avec un tableau on veut
préparer de certaines données alors
regardez ce sont les entrées donc au
canada en provenance des états unis en
2020 en comparaison avec 2010 9 alors
sur la frontière terrestre alors les
gens qui passent la frontière regarder
un recul entre 2020 et 2019 2 91% recul
de 95% dans les aéroports et ce qui est
intéressant c'est la dernière donnée
vous le voyez 0%
ça veut dire que c'est stable et les
transports des camionneurs à la
frontière alors on voit bien que malgré
la fermeture de la frontière monsieur
generis des échanges entre nos deux pays
se poursuivent actuellement toutes été
et c'était l'idée effectivement du
gouvernement canadien du gouvernement
américain où il ya eu cette négociation
pour la fermeture de la frontière
c'était d'avoir une fermeture de la
frontière qui permettent de répondre à
la crise annie sanitaires sans
handicaper trop fortement l'économie et
donc sans entraves et les échanges
commerciaux donc néanmoins si on regarde
les chiffres des douanes canadiennes qui
ont été publiés par cette can les
chiffres mensuels en valeur là on voit
valeur des exportations est la valeur
des importations a fortement baissé
on parle de quel est l'impact
actuellement donc on parle là en terme
d'ordre de grandeur
les exportations du canada vis-à-vis du
reste du monde ont baissé d'environ 40%
les importations d'un bon 30% qui est un
mais ces variations sont même encore
plus forte avec les états unis
et quels secteurs qui souffrent le plus
évidemment l'on passe au tourisme tout
de suite là et quels secteurs où on voit
davantage
donc si on regarde effectivement plutôt
au niveau du commerce de marchandises
effectivement un secteur qui est très
fortement impacté assez notamment le
secteur de l'industrie automobile est
une des raisons pour lesquelles
effectivement on se rend compte que la
baisse du commerce entre le canada
mais ses partenaires commerciaux est
plus forte avec les états unis
c'est justement en raison de ce commerce
très particulier lié aux chaînes
d'approvisionnement très intégré un
comme dans l'industrie automobile entre
le canada et les états unis
alors puisque si on est venu parce
qu'effectivement donc ce qu'il faut bien
avoir c'est que pour une voiture pour
une automobile qui est assemblée au
canada ou aux états unis
les composants de cette automobile sont
plusieurs fois l'aller-retour de part et
d'autre de la frontière
1 et puisque ça c'est parce que
effectivement les fournisseurs se
spécialise les uns et les autres chacun
sur un segment très précis d'activités
qu'ils savent faire le mieux mais donc
du tout un même composant passe
plusieurs fois la frontière et donc
lorsqu'il ya une voiture en moins de
fabriquer c'est en réalité beaucoup
moins en termes de commerce qui se passe
entre le canada les etats-unis en raison
de ce commerce qui est à la chaîne
d'appauvrir vous avez tout à fait raison
souvent vu des parties de la voiture
peut même se déplacer 15 fois donc à la
frontière se promener entre les états
unis ou le canada
cela dit on se pose la question à quand
la réouverture de la frontière parce que
beaucoup de nuages notamment aux états
unis
la situation ne s'améliore pas on a vu
des tristes records qu'on est en train
de battre surtout dans les états du sud
est ce que ça pourrait nous faire mal
ici au canada tout à fait alors là je
pense qu'il ya en fait deux questions
dans votre question
la première a pour la réouverture de la
frontière en réalité je pense que le
canada a pas très envie tant que la
situation sanitaire n'est pas maîtrisée
aux états unis devrait ouvrir la
frontière et de risquer d'avoir des
contaminations qui arrivent au canada en
raison de la situation non maîtrisée aux
états unis maintenant le problème c'est
que les négociations entre le canada et
les états unis sont toujours très
compliqué en raison de la dépendance
économique du canada vis-à-vis des
etats-unis ce qu'il faut réaliser c'est
que plus de 50 % 55 56 % des
importations à canadiennes sont des
importations de biens fabriqués aux
états unis mais en plus il ya tout un
tas de biens fabriqués en dehors des
états unis qui transitent par les états
unis pour arriver au canada est donc en
réalité c'est ce qu'on montre avec un
collègue julien martin pluess jeu car
c'est presque 80 cent des importations
canadiennes qui passe d'une manière ou
d'une autre par les états unis
et donc c'est pour ça que
le canada et le gouvernement fédéral
marche souvent un peu sur des oeufs
lorsqu'ils négocient avec quelqu'un
d'aussi imprévisible que donald trump à
la maison vous mourrez la porte parce
que vous parlez d'un autre chose c'est
qu'on est fortement à risque face au
protectionnisme
est ce que c'est un risque qui est
accrue avec la pandémie comme par
exemple les états unis pourraient
privilégier leur marché intérieur pour
éviter des pénuries
tout est est donc là je pense que ce qui
se passe avec la colite 19 montre à quel
point cette extrême dépendance du canada
vis-à-vis de son principal partenaire
commercial
les etats unis une dépendance qui est
vraiment très unie copain qui est unique
au monde parmi les pays développés à
elle pose problème vraiment très
fortement lorsqu'on a à de l'incertitude
et cette incertitude elle peut être
politique et donc c'est quand on a un
président américain aussi un premier
empereur aussi imprévisible que donald
trump
mais elle est aussi avec des événements
comme la copie dit il des raisons de la
baisse en valeur du commerce c'est que
lorsque les économies lorsque les états
unis ne vont pas bien et bien forcément
le canada étant fortement intégrée avec
les études les états unis en souffrent
aussi donc ça pose vraiment je pense de
manière très urgente à question de la
diversification des partenaires
commerciaux pour le canada de trouver
d'autres partenaires
c'est peut-être rapidement monsieur
trudeau vous savez que pour participer à
la rencontre à washington pour célébrer
l'entrée en vigueur du nouvel accord
commercial est ce qu'il faut il voir
dans un froid peut-être quinze minutes
15 secondes
oui non je pense que effectivement la
décision de ne pas y aller a obéi il ne
voulait pas être récupéré dans le cas de
la campagne présidentielle et par
ailleurs des tensions actuelles sur
notamment la question des tarifs entre
les bears
merci beaucoup monsieur médéric merci
d'avoir été avec nous